there are some other things that you can
do to celebrate halloween at home while
staying safe
here are some last-minute ideas from
lifestyle expert donna bozzo
oh my god you're so right halloween is
just around the corner and although many
events are cancelled
it doesn't mean you can't brew up your
own frightening
fun at home lots of us are planning to
celebrate the spooky season
at our own haunted houses this year i
say bring entertaining at home can be
wickedly fun
if well no bones about it here are some
easy ideas
your guests will love first of all start
with the invite
sure a simple text will do but a clever
invite will levitate your guests
expectations plus it says a really fun
vibe for the night um i love this idea
okay so this is
very harry potter send your invite
buy owl pick up some stuffed owls dollar
stores a good place to start
attach the party details kids will love
delivering this guests will love
receiving it
it's such a fun way to get everyone over
to celebrate halloween
and a lot of us will be taking the feast
outdoors this year of course that's kind
of
the way we all are working right now so
that means you need to find clever ways
to light up the night
keep the party going creative lighting
gets guests
into the spirit and lets follow the fun
creep into the night
think twinkle lights halloween lights
candles
or if you want to make your own
witchcraft i love glow sticks
i made this super fun lantern out of
vegetable
oil water and glow sticks
anything you can do to just keep it
going creepy decorations
also set the table and set the mood as
far as the food
home chef is my go-to when i want to
impress guests
without spending all day in the kitchen
you get everything you need to cook a
delicious
meal fresh pre-measured ingredients and
easy to follow recipes
created by professional chefs i just
love their
new heat and meat pizzas definitely a
halloween
crown pleaser you can find home chef at
smith's in the deli
section or you can order it online in
advance at home chef dot com
lastly don't forget the fun and games
throw out the arts and craft
projects project a halloween movie on
the garage door
have the kids all gather around popcorn
and movie candy or have the kids parade
around
in costumes super fun we've all waited
so long
to get back to the point where we can be
celebrating our traditional
holidays you'll definitely want to make
the freight fun
and create a night to remember happy
halloween everyone
have a fantastic time